[Música]
qué pasó en los mercados y cómo están
las noticias relacionadas con la
economía pues nos lo cuenta fue
resultado aquí en el estudio de directo
américa buenas noches jorge vamos a
comenzar hablando de rusia por fin
admitieron que las sanciones de
occidente van a golpear la economía de
ese país santiago lo dijo el ministerio
de economía asegura que este año es
economía se va a contraer en 7,8 por
ciento culpan a las sanciones de
occidente aunque la cifra está por
debajo de las predicciones del banco
central de una contracción de entre el 8
al 10 por ciento para este año según
este pronóstico la economía se
recuperará en 2023 con una leve
contracción del 0,7 por ciento y según
esta nueva proyección el pib ruso
crecería un 3,2 en 2024 y un 2,6 en 2025
el efecto de las sanciones comenzó a
sentirse en el primer trimestre en el
que el pib creció sólo un 1,6 por ciento
el presidente ruso dijo hoy que europa
estaría cometiendo un suicidio económico
al tratar de eliminar el suministro
energético ruso escuchemos
y ahora hablando con franqueza como
resultado de las acciones caóticas de
nuestros socios además del daño a la
propia economía europea estamos teniendo
realmente un aumento en los ingresos del
sector ruso del petróleo y el gas los
cambios en el mercado del petróleo son
de naturaleza tectónica y hacer negocios
como siempre según el viejo modelo
parece por supuesto improbable es
preocupante la situación en sí de la
ncaa jorge porque a partir de mañana
podría ser el último día con
combustibles esto no ayuda a esa crisis
social que hay en ese país asiático el
nuevo primer ministro ha admitido que
los próximos meses serán los más
difíciles que han vivido en la historia
de esa isla según el primer ministro la
nación necesita urgentemente 75 millones
de dólares los próximos días para pagar
las importaciones esenciales aseguró que
el banco central imprimirá dinero para
pagar los salarios del gobierno es
economía aún sufre los efectos
económicos de la pandemia y el aumento
de los precios de la energía la escasez
de divisas y la inflación provocaron
escasez de medicamentos combustibles y
otros productos básicos durante las
últimas semanas cientos de personas se
han manifestado contra el presidente
la bahía de rajapaksa y su familia la
semana pasada mahindra el hermano mayor
del presidente renunció como primer
ministro en medio de esas crisis
sociopolítica pasemos ahora a una
noticia positiva en eeuu las ventas de
las minoristas crecieron esto es bueno
para la economía bueno también es una
señal de que la demanda de mercancías
resiste pese a el alto acto de inflación
que se vive ahí el valor de las compras
minoristas totales aumentó un 0,9 por
ciento en abril según cifras del
departamento de comercio excluyendo
vehículos y gasolineras las ventas
crecieron un 1% el mes pasado los
estadounidenses siguen gastando en
mercancías a un ritmo acelerado incluso
cuando los precios registran las mayores
alzas en décadas el gasto del consumidor
es el factor que más contribuye a la
economía estadounidense y se prevé que
caiga en los próximos meses debido al
fin del estímulo federal noticias de la
región washington parece rebajar las
sanciones y las restricciones hacia cuba
ya venezuela lo hemos reportado en este
informativo el departamento de estado
anunció que eliminará el límite de 1000
dólares por trimestre para las remesas
familiares y permitirá el envío de
remesas no familiares una noticia de los
pequeños negocios de cuba recibieron con
buenos ojos varias de estas
restricciones fueron impuestas durante
la administración de donald trump
escuchemos que dicen ahí los cubanos
resulta totalmente impredecible
ya muchas promesas se han dado
anteriormente
seguimos en las mismas no sé solamente
nos queda esperar a ver si nos favorece
sino si sucede sin tirar celebrar
demasiado pero tengo una buena noticia
después de tanto en tantas de las
noticias en los últimos años también el
gobierno de joe biden autorizaría a la
compañía petrolera estadounidense
chevron iniciar negociaciones con la
estatal venezolana a pedevesa tron había
emitido varias sanciones contra
venezuela que incluyeron la prohibición
de comercializar bonos del tesoro
venezolano en los mercados financieros
de eeuu o hacer negocios con esta
petrolera tras la guerra en operan en
eeuu inició un diálogo con el gobierno
de venezuela estas aperturas se dan tras
las críticas a washington por no invitar
a representantes de cuba venezuela y
nicaragua a la cumbre de las américas
que se va a realizar próximamente en los
ángeles california los mercados como las
faldas principales bolsas en el día de
hoy empecemos con wall street que donde
un pequeño rebote y terminó con una
fuerte subida impulsada por apple tesla
y otros valores de crecimiento de media
capital en europa con una subida del
1,59
ciento impulsado por los buenos
resultados del fabricante de camiones de
1000 truck cerró el frankfurt de
alemania en américa latina la bolsa
mexicana de valores registró ganancias
del 1 78 por ciento en su principal
indicador
complementando seis sesiones
consecutivas en las que cierra con
buenos avances porque muchas gracias nos
queda viendo la cifra del día ustedes
sigan con nosotros que ya estamos listos
para el debate
[Música]